mes chers compatriotes dimanche prochain
vous serez appelés à désigner vos
députés qui constitueront l'assemblée
nationale et qui d'une certaine manière
définiront les grands choix d'avenir
pour le pays pour les cinq années qui
viennent ce choix il est important il
doit se faire dans la clarté clarté sur
les hommes et les femmes qui composent
les candidatures retenues pour le second
tour nous portons également un projet
qui renonce définitivement à toute
augmentation d'impôts nous ne voulons
pas de la vente la csg pour les
retraités nous ne voulons pas la hausse
de la csg pour les fonctionnaires nous
ne voulons pas de la hausse de la csg
pour les indépendants nous ne voulons
pas de l'impact de la hausse de la csg
pour celles et ceux qui ont d'epargne
donc tout travail supplémentaire soit
mieux rémunéré notamment grâce à la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires parce que nous croyons
au travail
nous voulons que l'augmentation du temps
de travail se traduisent par un gain de
pouvoir d'achat
nous voulons rendre du pouvoir d'achat
aux français pour qu'ils puissent
profiter des fruits de leur travail à
travers la baisse de 10% de l'impôt sur
le revenu nous voulons que les retraités
notamment les plus modestes puissent
pleinement bénéficié de l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat que nous proposons
avec la revalorisation des pensions
nous voulons pas qu'ils soient les
cibles de la hausse spectaculaire de la
csg nous voulons que les délinquants
récidivistes soit condamner plus
sévèrement c'est le sens des peines
planchers de nous rétablir en voulant
que la france puisse choisir qui elle
accueille sur son territoire notamment
grâce aux quotas d'immigration voter
annuellement par le parlement nous
voulons donner aux forces de l'ordre les
moyens de protéger les français
la police et la gendarmerie verront
leurs effectifs augmenter les dix mille
personnes
nous ne voulons laisser aucun répit à ce
défi l'autorité de l'état
nous avons des convictions nous les
gardons et nous les affiches on nous
sommes la droite et le chante et nous
n'avons pas à en rougir
je voudrais que nous reprenions le
flambeau du progrès de l'avenir que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir brandir d'une
main audacieuse et sans ambiguïté nous
voulons que les agriculteurs puissent
également bénéficier de la baisse des
charges et des
il est urgent de mettre fin à la sueur
transposition européenne qui les
pénalise
ce sont les premiers acteurs de la
préservation du paysage de notre
environnement nous devons leur faire
confiance
il n'y a pas d'un côté la france de
métropole et de l'autre la france
périurbaines et rurales à chaque euro
investi dans la ville ils investiront un
euro dans la ruralité d'ici à 2022 nous
viserons un reste à charge 0 pour les
dépenses de santé les plus coûteuses
nous voulons pas que les français
renoncent à se soigner pour des raisons
financières
nous ne voulons pas laisser des jeunes
quitter l'école sans savoir lire écrire
compter et connaître l'histoire de notre
pays nous avons une équipe rassemblée
soudée nous avons un renouvellement
forts de nos candidats nos jeunes hommes
et femmes qui incarnent une génération
qui se lève qui demande un espoir
ils sont là au rendez-vous et sont à vos
côtés ils portent cette volonté
d'engagement total au service de notre
pays ils sont le visage de la france une
france construite sur ses racines et
fière de son histoire
ils sont de droite et du centre et ils
en sont fiers
dimanche prochain mobilisez vous allez
voter
mobilisez vos pendant une semaine entre
à suivre pour de nos candidats de la
droite et du centre comme mobilisez-vous
comme certaines idées il pas de
républicains pour les grands choix
l'avenir pour les uns cantine et donnons
une majorité pour la franche pour que
vive la république
et pour qu'elle vive la france
[Musique]